[Music]
at weapons and bombs
b-24s would I
we call upon revolutionary movements
everywhere to focus the attention of the
world on the Palestinian people's
struggle
welcome to Entebbe Uganda there are 239
hostages at Entebbe 83 are Israeli the
Germans separated the juice we have to
act
there could be no negotiations with
terrorists you want to invent Uganda she
would we give it back to them when we
live this man bear no grudge against you
but if your government do not Lukas it
they would kill two children every 24
hours anyone who resists me will be shot
if you want to take control of the
airport I'm gonna have to use a much
bigger force but it's impossible to move
a force of that size 4000 kilometres are
detected we can't just sit here do
nothing why have you here want to throw
bombs into the consciousness of the
masses and what if you have to throw her
you're my friend are you ready to kill
are you ready to die all the officials
in Uganda use a black limousine that
gives us the element of surprise
if the mission fails the blow to Israel
will be catastrophic we stop for nothing
until all the hostages are safe
here we go
they have TNT on the claim and all
around the building
as soon as they know we're coming they
start to kill the men the women the
children they want the world to watch
[Music]
whatever happens we did the right thing
[Music]
[Music]
you